you only fell when you stopped trying
keeping this as my life mantra i started
looking for a job after completion of my
bsc in statistics from nisam college in
2020
since the lockdown imposed the
possibility of getting jobs or very less
i felt insecure about my career although
i was top scorer throughout my academics
my wishes suggested that it's better to
move to the idea industry and personally
i also witnessed that world is in the
process of digitalization and automation
and there is a huge scope of quality to
developers and at that time i have no
prior knowledge in coding i wanted to
thank you the simplest fsd course with
the job guarantee i got hired at a
salesforce developer with live area
within 1.5 months after the completion
of the course hi this is vitter nayak
and i am from a small town of telangana
and i am proud to be a alumni of
simplyla
i wanted to acquire the skills and
skills set that are required to be it
professional so
i searching and online courses and
that's where i get to know about the
simplyland fsd course i decided to
enroll it after hearing the good reviews
and quora and my friends and relatives
also this course was perfect for me as i
had no prior experience in this field
from world's best faculties i felt the
course to be tough for me but the entire
course has been a life changing
experience for me the trainer is very
experienced and helped me even with more
questions as well the pre-recording
content and live interactive sessions
are very helpful to understand the
concepts the course content is up to
date and designed in beginner-friendly
manner the fsd certification has brought
my career path back a drug what i
learned in the course is very helpful
for me as a salesforce developer i had a
dream of working with bank companies and
this course had shown me the path to
upskilling and reaching my goals i got
good amount of exposure and chance to
interact with trainers and peers
throughout the course it helped me to
develop my communication skills which i
was lacking i didn't know about the
corporate communication skills but
trainer taught me how to do it and
proper interaction it's wrong to say
that there are no jobs in the market we
need to have right skills and in the end
it's not your school and college
percentage matters
but the job ready skills you acquired so
keep up skilling yourself